all of us are gonna be very heated today
and we're gonna have to take turns are
we gonna have to be heated uh
eric are you excited about this podcast
or what no no not at all
[Laughter]
that's a good one that's a good place to
start eric wants to stay up in his ivory
tower and as soon as culture war then
he's like
nah i'm above this i'm floating in the
clouds above this
eric just pound a few beers
yeah i'm already i'm already through a
bit of tequila
i'm feeling actually much more mellow
than i should be probably oh whatever
i was gonna say you need to like let the
dark side flow through you
let the anger exactly
listeners what's up um we were planning
to move into marks
as was promised because the entire the
entire reason that we tried to go
through hegel was to at least give us
some grounding
to okay someone's got a police
oh sorry yeah the fire the fire stations
right by my house
it's not the police it's the fire don't
worry they're out
the fire is not unauthorized marxist
podcast
yeah they're coming to get all those
post-modern neo-marxists
rounding them up as i was saying we were
planning to move into marx but then we
had to call this emergency pod
because of an article that appeared in
the culture war skirmishes
this week so we will get to marx
eventually
i'm gonna have to brush up on my reading
myself but for now
we're gonna descend from our lofty
towers in uh
elysium our ivory towers and
come get our feet wet down on earth i
think we might get some heat on this
episode that we don't usually get so if
you don't know us
we have a lot of letters behind our name
which we think
provides us with the modicum of
authority to wade into this [ __ ]
um by the way guys this the e filter the
explicit filter is gonna be on
for today so pop your beers
and uh rant away [ __ ] yeah
you beat me to it victor before we get
into this event this colossal event
in the world of internet leftism i just
wanted to ask you guys a question
do you believe in marxists
not do you believe in marxism but do you
believe in marxists do i believe they
exist
well we had a self-avowed marxist on the
last episode my understanding is they're
kind of like santa claus
you know they don't really appear except
on those very special revolutionary
periods where they arrive and they
disseminate theory to the masses
who then spontaneously rise up and
create a society full of pornographers
and transgendered people
and lesbians and all kinds of other
wonderful things
oh yeah but i'm not sure and yeah no
doubt about that
boy i don't know i might have to be a
contrarian on this because uh there
definitely are
a lot of uh marxists who believe in
themselves at least are like unironic
marxists
in grad school at least humanities and
english programs so
this is just you you kind of notice
these guys because they tend to kind of
like
name drop like commodity fetishism like
more often than rudy giuliani mentions
911 so you can kind of
you pick it up after a while even if the
conversation has nothing to do with like
marxism it's like oh yeah
the author is clearly fetishizing x and
y subjects so
yeah i'm i'm not sure how much like
they're actually familiar with the
theoretical end of things but it does
seem to have become
the kind of default counter cultural
stance in some circles at least in grad
school so
yeah i mean i was thinking i was
thinking about our first actually ever
pilpot episode where we talked about the
zizek versus peterson debate
and i remember there's a key moment in
that debate where zija kind of pushes
peterson and says you know who are these
marxists you're talking about
right like in the university like
there's really none not that many left
at all like it's like you know there's
people who buy who are into
post-modern philosophy or people who
draw on foucault or these other
streams but like actual marxists
certainly not so much in political
science departments yeah
he's like there's very there's very few
left and um
so i think in that to that extent like
maybe the answer would be
there there's a i mean even somebody
like i don't know if you guys are
familiar with richard wolff
it's like that that marks that alleged
marxist economist
and he's like kind of a marxist but he's
a very
he i think he believes in marx's
critique in fact
if i would rephrase this i would say
there are a lot of people in academia
who
who uh employ and find useful mark the
marxist form of critique
to critique the economy but in terms of
marxists who actually believe in
the kind of old-fashioned version of
marxist revolution i think there's like
less of those like because
even someone like richard wolf his ideas
like we have to bring more democracy to
the workplace
like that's basically his form of
marxism is like let's democratize the
workplace
like does thinking about marxism a
marxist make
because you can be a hegelian and all
you have to do
is let history think through you and
there
bang you are a hegelian but
a marxist they have material
responsibilities right you have to
you have to be seizing stuff it's not
like
you have you put a bunch of buttons on
your back and now you're our your
backpack and now you're a marxist or
wear like uh black skinny jeans
now you're a marxist and smoked
cigarettes every marxist smoke
cigarettes
that's true i mean the ones alleged
alleged marxists
but if you're paying rent are you a
marxist
you are if you hit your landlord that's
that's the rule
you got to always be like complaining
about the landlord yeah
and smoking cigarettes when you're not
supposed to really important
you never there's no such thing as a
smoke-free apartment if you're a marxist
right
i mean i'm totally willing to accept
that lenin was a marxist but even lenin
said i'm not a marxist i'm a russian
communist
right i believe marx at one point said
i'm not a marxist uh
marxism means whatever these people are
invoking in my name so
now these controversies go way back to
the 19th century yeah it's interesting
the struggle to
uh to to identify under a certain ism
but then even yeah it's funny even the
source of that is like well i'm not this
so it's just it's already it's
it's been a contested concept for so
long now that it's like
i mean so that makes it actually a good
question to ask like are there actually
marxists
i should say that one of the interesting
things about this doctrine is just
understandably more than any other one
that i can think of that
emerged from professor's pen this
provokes the most polarizing reactions
like there are some political theorists
and serious academics i know who will
say
if you're marxist this is just dribble
why are you bothering with that any
longer it's 19th century economics at
best
you know if the little hegelianism
splashed in i think foucault
uh ironically considering he's also
lumped uh with these postmodern neon
marxists
once said that marx was boring and you
know he didn't really find much of use
to it
uh and then you contrast that with some
other reactions uh
like martin hagland i just finished his
book this life and he almost gives marx
a religious
significance right saying marx
prophesies a new era of spiritual life
that was to come once we were all free
of wage labor under capitalism uh
and this is you know a society that's
yet to come
but it's what we should all be striving
for if we're genuinely
faithful people uh who have any sense of
humanity and any care for freedom
well we are not done the intro yet so i
i think i need a sound effect that i can
just drop in
after every name drop specifically for
matt
so hagelind count what's up listener
can we just use like the international
or something like that
you were listening to the pill pod
today is eric matthew victor
and victor second victor yeah litvic
lit vik who we are also calling ussr
baby so
he's very familiar with marxism true
true to form martial you may remember
from the u.s
episode too so east meets west here
eastern bloc
victor and the pill pod if you don't
know
is the podcast where we only use the
word comrade on ironically
in bed so how are you doing comrades
good brother we've been doing some heavy
[ __ ] for the last few weeks
many have said that our episode last
week was the best one ever
many are saying it it's a wrap well matt
h said it
and he's our most dedicated listener and
the one who single-handedly saved this
podcast
when we were all about to quit so if you
want to listen to the best
episode ever you have to sign up for the
patreon yeah
oh right that was a patreon only episode
right and if you are a patron
i will under on i'll not ironically call
you comrade
everyone has a price it's it's it's
called capitalism
that was an epic so i have to say like
it was just i actually felt like i had
read through the phenomenology of spirit
again after you've done that thing
because i was just like man we covered a
[ __ ] lot of topics
yeah that was fun it was so if you want
it it's called pillpod12
become a patron today yeah it's on uh
what was it called again something just
like dialectic of recognition
i gotta get mad props to borno also you
know oh yeah burner was great yeah
yeah no he [ __ ] took like the most
difficult theorist i could possibly
think of and really managed to make it
seem relatively accessible and not just
like accessible but like
vital and it's so much nicer in over
video chat than i imagined him to be
because on the
on the chat he was like he seemed like
defensive of the proper
interpretation of hegel but then when he
was actually there he was like so nice
and like
charitable and amicable
dude yeah i still feel kind of inhibited
not because of borna
just because hagel is such a that's such
a
thing getting hegel wrong getting marks
wrong
like i don't nobody cares if you get
like freud or darwin wrong but if you
get marx and hegel wrong it's like
yes i mean if you get freud wrong it's
just because you're oppressing your own
sexuality eric that's the problem
yeah there's a there's a talking cure
for that
but with marx it's like you've betrayed
the revolution
well i mean if you get freud wrong it's
because you don't realize that you just
want to bang
your psychoanalyst and you gotta get
past that
so without further ado
sopranos just came out let's talk about
getting marks wrong
because matt thanks a [ __ ] lot you
made us read
the worst thing i have ever read
for this week link in the description
do not click on it i warned you and i
know you're [ __ ] gonna do it anyway
this is not an endorsement either of the
article or the website because both
are dog [ __ ] anyway
matt what did you make us read this week
yeah tell us about it uh so it was an
article
in um the kind of center right uh
publication colette which you know
full disclosure i published with uh
quite a bit back in the day
uh that was before it turned into more
of a it's such
it's become so much more of a right-wing
echo chamber than it used to be i feel
like
well the reason that i did it was
actually because i wanted to reach out
to conservatives and convince them that
the left wasn't scary
and also i wasn't afraid of actually
arguing with their ideas but that's you
know
neither here nor there uh the piece was
by joram hazoni who's the author of the
virtual
the virtue of nationalism uh which one
conservative book of the year back in
2019
uh and it's on the dangers posed by
marxism
and why it is that liberals need to
unite with conservatives
in order to banish the specter of
marxism from the universities from
culture from the media
and everywhere else where it's managed
to get its tentacles embedded yeah and
if that makes it sound more exciting
it's not take it from us five of us read
it
you can skip it yeah yeah but although
we'll talk about it here we'll talk
about this yeah
so you don't have to look at it so that
you don't have to exactly
i want to say just just in defense of
the article
i actually thought it was really
interesting not as a piece of
intellectual history or commentary
because i don't think that it's really
very good on those fronts
but as a kind of artifact that
synthesized
a lot of right-wing stereotypes and
concerns about marx together
into a singular whole it's really kind
of fascinating
because i don't know any other
conservative commentator who's
done this at such length and so publicly
is a zoni even somebody like
jordan peterson who rants on and on
about postmodern neo-marxism or ben
shapiro or whatever
has never kind of made a statement about
this um
you're totally right in some sense the
it's true like the feeling i got when i
was reading it
was that that like i was exactly reading
something that all of these figures you
just named like peterson shapiro like
ruben
right if they read it they'd be like
they would be like yes this is what i've
been trying to say
all this time but now it's been said
perfectly in a way and if you want an
endorsement
it's also been endorsed by ted cruz
who yeah ted cruz tweeted about it noted
werewolf ted cruz
came out of his cave to
oh did we export him to why are we just
exporting the
yeah he was born in california and is
the zodiac killer apparently
we're not sending the us our best
unfortunately
unlike mexico
guys i i do got a shout out because i
was checking i was checking our stats
we have a lot of listeners in texas so
comrades
i say this unironically we feel your
pain
living under the zodiac killer werewolf
ted cruz
long live beto and the revolution yeah
but you know seriously though this
article was um
it just felt like a more sophisticated
uh like the jordan peterson view of just
that marxism is
anything that involves oppressor and
oppressed is like marxism in addition to
a few other things but that's really
what it felt like a very which by the
way if that's
if that's like a crucial feature of
marxism then you know aristotle is a
marxist because in the politics he says
that uh
you know class we have to correct for
class antagonisms because you have two
if you have too many rich and poor
people
then uh the whole society is going to
fall apart so like by that logic it just
seems like
uh even aristotle would be a marxist at
least in part
well-known he's a well-known marxist
that aristotle
or even the american revolutionaries
right yeah aristotle was a great reader
of marx
well you can't disprove it
if it's in colette then it's true it's
the same way that the beatles were great
interpreters uh
of oasis right but um no i just figure
we should summarize it briefly so
according in hazoni's article he claims
that there are four fundamental features
uh to the marxist political framework
the first one is that marx argues
that all societies are divided into
oppressor and oppressed classes and that
the state tends to enforce
the interest of the oppressed of the
oppressor classes
secondly that there's a kind of false
consciousness that's disseminated
across the body of the population as an
official ideology
this means that both oppressor and
oppressed aren't always aware of the
dynamic that they're actually involved
in
they may even think that it's
justifiable thirdly
that there needs to be a revolutionary
reconstitution of society uh that ends
with the destruction of the
suppressor class and his replacement uh
with a regime that's considerably more
equal
and this will of course be a violent
revolution uh and then finally for and
fourthly
um that marx has been characterized by
the desire to end class antagonisms
uh through establishing a utopian state
and sony argues that how this is to be
done is never specified so those are the
four features that he associates with
marxism
right and what's different about
peterson because i have actually
you said this is better than peterson's
reading of marx it's more sophisticated
i didn't say it's better
um and i thought it was more flav or
peterson is more insipid because
he doesn't actually use the words this
guy made an effort to use
the words like uh false consciousness
historical materialism and class
struggle except he managed
to twist these words so they're so
unrecognizable
from what marx was actually talking
about so i want to ask you guys how do
we approach this do we want to
debunk any of these claims even with our
paltry knowledge of marx
or do we want to talk about why he wrote
this article
i think we could probably do a little
bit of both but i would lean a little
bit more
towards the ladder just because doing
doing a deep
frankly i'm sure all we're going to do
doing a debunk is not always like uh the
most necessarily interesting thing yeah
i mean you don't have to go like
point by point you can just kind of like
attack the premise of what he's even
arguing here because he's coming at this
from a very specific kind of like cold
war mindset
and that's sort of like the main problem
well kind of can i can i yeah i mean one
thing
i'll give you the premise just the first
okay the opening bit
um well okay we thought that 1989 ended
marxism quote a mere 30 years later
marxism is back and making an
astonishingly successful bid to seize
control
of the most important american media
companies universities
schools corporations philanthropic
organizations
courts government bureaucracy and
churches and that'd be pretty
interesting in marx's church
so red scare basically yeah that's the
whole ground
of the argument is that there's some
kind of
marxist takeover going on like that's
what everything everything lives or dies
on is that [ __ ] true is is there a
marxist takeover i mean forget about
forget about the uh increasing wealth
gap forget about the centralization of
control the media
forget about corporate ownership there's
a marxist takeover going on beneath all
of that other crap
and that's what we have to do i forget
that like donald trump isn't
his evidence like this is the this is
the [ __ ] empirical point that
everything in this
article rests on and like is it [ __ ]
true
is it true i don't know if it is if it's
obviously i don't know about it well
this is why i asked the question at the
beginning
do we believe in marxist so we're gonna
go to matt first and then to victor
okay okay cool uh well i have an article
coming out explaining
why it is that i don't uh like this or
don't agree with it um
at great length uh so i'll just be
really brief here
and what are what where are you
publishing it uh it's gonna be in
jacobin
uh i don't know when it'll come out
probably pretty soon but that's but
that's a marxist publication so we can't
believe anything they say
no i think it would be the mainstream
media dominant jacobin
magazine widely read by millions it is
i mean i'm getting paid i'm getting paid
almost a million dollars just for this
piece right
because we have so many corporate owners
who are willing to donate to us
don't tell anyone that but you know uh
my house is going to be financed uh on
the uh like on the basis of this article
but but no basically in some i think the
biggest problem with this piece
is if you read it he treats marxism
primarily as a political doctrine about
oppressor and oppressed
classes and nowhere in this entire piece
uh does the concept of political economy
arise
which is shocking when you think that
marx's two most famous books
are both entitled a critique of
political economy
our contribution to the critique of
political economy and this is really
telling right because
for hazoni the only thing that's
significant about marxism is this notion
that there's an oppressor and that
there's an oppressed class
and he's kind of tired of leftists
rallying behind
the oppressed classes to try to change
the status quo he doesn't mind
invoking the suppressor a press
narrative when it comes to conservative
groups that he feels are being oppressed
by nasty liberals and progressives
but generally people shouldn't be doing
that uh and when you do that you lose a
lot that's
distinctive about marxism uh and just
treat it
like some kind of pastiche of itself
because marxism without a critique of
political economy really isn't much of a
doctrine at all
um there's nothing distinct or
interesting about it it's a rum and coke
without the rum exactly right i wouldn't
even call it coke it's more like that pc
brand or no-name brand called rc cola
yeah
and i think what makes this interesting
though
is that this is a very typical gesture
on the part of a lot
of political conservatives who endeavor
to try to
dissociate marxism from its embeddedness
in hegelian philosophy
in the critique of capitalist political
economy because all that stuff's fairly
sophisticated
and would involve some real arguments uh
to actually
undermine uh and they try to treat it
like it's just some kind of
rhetorical political doctrine about a
press or a press class that can be
easily dismissed
uh as basically whining uh on the part
of certain groups of people
uh and once it's dismissed you don't
have to really deal with it any longer
uh which of course is not the case since
we're living in a late capitalist
post-modern society
uh and if anything a lot of what marx
has to say is
more descriptively telling i think than
it ever has been before
and i think this is what they're
ultimately worried about even if they
don't express that explicitly
uh in a lot of police pieces like that
so that's just my take on this yeah i
know all right so i thank you for
keeping it short
i i assume that's short for matt mcmanus
oh it is
i could rant about this forever so i
think so so i think it's very telling
also that like
like at the beginning of part two he he
basically uh like this is his evidence
for saying that things are marxist or at
least part of it he says you know
when people you know who he's referring
to as marxist he's like they'll
disorient their opponents by referring
to their beliefs
with a shifting vocabulary of terms
including the left progressivism social
justice
anti-racism anti-fascism black lives
matter
critical race theory identity politics
political correctness wokeness and more
so he's basically admitting he's
literally telling you right there in
that sense
i am conflating marxism with basically
everything that i don't like
that's but he's so frustrating he's
saying you
are confusing me by turning your marxism
into all these terms
when he is the one turning marxism into
all these terms
exactly i mean the idea that these
groups might actually believe different
things and have different agendas this
is just
really foreign to this piece's
imagination right it's like
really like black lives matter uh you
know
is a marxist movement was martin luther
king a marxist you know
was abraham lincoln a marxist when he
decided to end slavery what the hell is
going on here
yeah i mean the fact that he's just
folks so focused on this oppressor and
oppressed relationship which
was also i think what jordan peterson
was obsessed with it and like you said
like
like ignoring the political economy is
so crucial and i kind of think
it's telling i i almost when i read this
and also listen there's also a cool at
podcast where he they interview the
author
and when i listen to it i got this like
strange feeling like almost
conspiratorial
that there's like a strategy behind this
almost and like here's kind of my
like half-baked conspiracy theory is
like it almost seems like these
argumentative moves by conflating
all these different things with marxism
it's like he's giving his fellow
conservatives or other readers who lean
conservative
the authority by writing this very
sophisticated piece to be like oh like
that's what marxism is
i knew it all along i don't have to
think about marxism i'd have to take
marx's critique seriously anymore
this guy's told me what marxism is and i
know that it's all those things that are
bad
and the other move that he makes which i
think is really interesting
is uh he basically talks about how
liberalism sets the stage
for this right he says liberalism uh
by like by degrading uh like traditional
values
opens the door to being able to to
complain about all these little
grievances
that people feel they're being
misrecognized in society or oppressed in
society so he's almost like doing a
double takedown where he can be like
okay like liberalism
it's their fault for uh for for opening
the door to
uh complaints about being about feelings
of oppressed from dif
from of oppression from different
classes and uh so now we can like it's
like
an attempted takedown of like liberalism
and what he's calling
marxism but then all the while he's not
even actually telling us anything about
what marxism really is
um yeah so i'll i'll interject on that
point just to say
yes there is an oppressor and an
oppressed in marx
it's the bourgeoisie and the proletariat
but he
generalizes this to say that there's
always classes and they're always trying
to exploit each other which
no the only exploitation that occurs
here is not
due to fairness it's not about being
unfair
it's a being it's one class owns the
surplus labor
of another class that's it it's not
about it's it's a measurable
effect and you can measure that and he
says like this is a quote
marx argues that as an empirical matter
people invariably form themselves into
cohesive groups
he calls them classes which exploit one
another to the extent
that they're able and this is not what
marx is saying he's not saying that we
have like
20 groups everywhere he's saying we have
a group of owners
and those owners own the labor of the
people who don't
own their own labor and that's what
there's no they don't form themselves
into these groups based on identities
it's just who owns what all you have to
do is open your eyes
see who owns what and then you have
classes
i want to interject also here because i
think uh rizzoni said something that was
really smart uh
and then i'm actually gonna pass it on
to litvik as was called because i think
that he could maybe
uh clarify some of the things that i'm
thinking about here uh because i think
what personality said was really
accurate right that the problem with
these kind of pieces is it's really easy
for us to sit here and pick on it
from our standpoint you know as
academics and being like he doesn't
understand marxism he doesn't know what
it's about
but people don't really accept uh like
uh people in our position don't always
understand
that these pieces have a really powerful
rhetorical effect uh particularly
amongst conservative and liberal
audiences because
hazonia is a respected intellectual
right he wrote a prestigious book
that won a beige a prize you know he
went to princeton
and when he says this is what marxism is
and this is why you should dismiss it
there's a huge number of people who will
say well if a smart guy with all these
kind of credentials is claiming this is
what marxism is
and we can dismiss it then that's just
what we ought to do right
uh and this is why you can't just sit
there and say wow this is dumb
let's ignore it it needs to be kind of
engaged with right exactly exactly
and i figured litvik probably knows why
it is that these rhetorical strategies
knowing we're concerned you're
absolutely right matt because to that
point there is this whole like sort of
industry out there which is a kind of
like using the specter of marxism to
kind of publish articles and kind of
like feed this whole like
audience but this really kind of seems
to go back to
the cold war mentality that the author
clearly is kind of coming from because
i don't know if you guys remember like
those commercials in the 80s or if
you've heard of them like
there's a bear in the woods some people
say the bear is safe
who knows for sure it's like vote reagan
and the bear is a soviet union basically
it's this ultimate appeal to emotions it
has nothing to do with the actual
ideology of marxism or anything like
that
but it's much more about this manichaean
struggle between the us
and the evil empire and so back then
obviously the evil empire was the soviet
union
clear marxist identified as communists
but once that collapsed
a lot of these analysts and kind of like
think tanks in dc and everything didn't
really have this
adversary right so for a while it was
kind of maybe
you know the war on terror radical islam
was sort of the new
bear in the woods but example fascism
yeah
exactly and they tried to like call it
fascism or even marxism but that didn't
really work
because it was so structurally different
but now i guess what's exciting
uh people like the author here is that
you do have
sort of like quote unquote
self-identified marxists again in
the west and so the bear is back the
boogeyman is back right
and this opens like the sort of industry
up again for talking about
marxism and communism in that in that
way yeah
and this is what i find fascinating
about this article because it really is
a kind of systematic
outline of that kind of affective world
view right that these marxists are
everywhere
they're taking over the media they're
taking over culture they're taking over
academia right you know when we need to
stop them because they're omnipresent
right you should you should you should
add this to your syllabus about uh
conservative political thought it's like
it's such an interesting piece for that
reason to actually read in that context
yeah like as a typological piece it's
really quite fascinating at least to me
uh but i kind of have a
perverse interest in these things yeah
uh you said a word uh litvik that i
wrote down as well
manikin and this is trying to get a
little bit away
from what he's actually saying because i
i
i'm having a really hard time even
considering that he believes what he's
saying
but this manichaeanism that you can
conjure
up this sort of world picture that's so
simplistic
and i would be shocked even teaching
like second-year undergraduates i would
be
shocked to get a paper like this because
it's so
conspiratorial in a cosmological sense
that there's this lovecraft cthulhu
devil
like living in the sewers creeping up to
actually destroy
civilization and this is theory for like
the 20 year olds
of course the 20 year olds who just
finished 12 rules for life
and they want like some more politics to
engage in
but i i cannot think that he can believe
this
and if he can and all the comments by
the way on this article
are like this is the most important
thing i've ever read i can't believe
it's taking someone so long to say this
and i i think i might just be an
academic
elitist or disconnected with this line
of thinking
because i cannot fit this in my head as
anything beyond a rhetorical strategy
because if some people can believe this
then
yeah i'm at a lot of words it's it's
definitely like a remnant of the sort of
geopolitical binary though from the 80s
where this guy clearly kind of like grew
up because
you did kind of have the sort of
struggle between east and west then
reagan and gorbachev and everything but
now he's sort of applying it in a very
sloppy way
to university campuses and sort of the
west
the western context in north america
where clearly that kind of mannequinism
is
laughable yeah as you're saying well so
so what i was saying before too about
like
this this being a potential strategy
like i agree
pills that you know it's hard to believe
that this is serious
in a sense which is what like makes me
think that there's a strategy
like some kind of a strategy behind this
because i think like often
when academics get a bit nitpicky about
using the correct words right and like i
think we do have that tendency and i
could imagine someone being like okay
well
whatever is it mark's sister is it not
marxist like that's beside the point
like are the things he's describing
actually happening right like someone
might ask that
and you know to some extent you could
say yeah sure like some of these things
that you're describing about like
wokeness or whatever
they're happening but like to call them
marxists like this is where i think the
strategy part comes in right because
by be by saying that these things are
marxist
then you're like you're authorizing the
dismissal of actual marxism which
you know doing a class analysis doing an
economic analysis of society of
of like how money is spread through our
society income inequality
like if you're a conservative like
that's maybe that's like a scary thing
to do so
it makes sense to be like oh no like
this is marxism
don't look at marxism you know and i'm
not a marxist like this is coming from
someone who is not a marxist
but i value marxist and economic
analysis and i can see that there's
something insidious about
you know like labeling something that
isn't marxist marxism
and then that that authorizes people to
just be like i'm never going to look at
marxism
actually mark there has to be dark money
behind this though or something
because it seems like like bernie is a
third of the way
to marxism and he got [ __ ] owned he
got eviscerated by all of these
institutions that are supposedly marxist
exactly i also think there's uh
there's an important in there's another
important insidious aspect to this piece
which unless someone wants to pick up on
something exactly that matt said
but i kind of want to like also flag
again
the like which i think is almost the
scarier part of this piece
which is the the critique of liberalism
itself the attack on liberalism as a
principle because
the one of the moves he makes which i
think like from a rhetorical perspective
is kind of interesting and smart
is like he says look liberalism has the
basic claim that all people are free and
equal
right and like so like liberalism is the
way that affirms everybody's equal
dignity
right everyone has equal freedom but
then based from that foundation then you
can start making claims and pointing to
classes in groups of people who aren't
actually free and equal and then that
creates this cycle where then the
marxist will come in and be like well
look no one's free and equal based on
liberalism
so we have to bring uh marxist
revolution
and then that creates this what he calls
like the this marxist liberal cycle i
forget the exact term he uses
and like i think what's kind of
insidious about that is this is a covert
um argument for traditional
like conservative values because what
he's saying is like liberalism is based
on this
like he doesn't actually say this but
like i feel like there's a subtext
that like um you know people aren't free
and equal like we should like maybe
that's an idea that we need to like let
go of and return to some sort of
traditional society that values certain
things hierarchically i don't know if
you guys agree maybe that's too much too
much reading into it but like
that's sort of the the the sense i got
from reading this this sort of attack on
the idea of equality as being
responsible for
yeah i mean a lot of it reminded me of a
joke and uh the crying of lot 49 by
thomas pynchon
where the main character encounters a
bunch of hyper-conservatives
uh who turn out to be
really anti-capitalist and she asked
them like why is it you're
anti-capitalist exactly and they're like
you just don't understand
we're anti-capitalist because capitalism
creates marxists
uh and you know we can't have that right
and this article seemed of a type with
that kind of joke because
the audit has a really tangential
relationship with
liberalism because on the one hand he
doesn't like its commitment
to moral equality and to freedom and he
sees those
as genealogically prior to the emergence
of marxism as a doctrine that
also respects freedom and equality but
radicalizes that by saying
even liberal society isn't enough on the
one hand
i think the reason why he's making the
kind of gesture at the end of the
article
towards liberals is because he knows
that tactically
uh the people in the liberal center are
either going to align with the political
left people like bernie sanders people
like aoc and so on
or they're going to align with the
political right and
the political right can't win if
liberals decide to side with the
political left
so he needs to try to entice them in uh
even though
he himself is not particularly
predisposed to liking liberalism all
that much
since it's basically just a better or
less radical
variant of what marxism as he
understands it uh stands for you know
what i mean
and to that point yeah he's also like
exploiting divisions probably within
like the current democratic party where
there clearly are two different wings
and he's basically telling like the old
school democrats
look if you're not with like the aoc
bernie sanders wing then you have to be
a republican conservative because
otherwise
look at the doomsday scenario that i'm
laying out so yeah to your point victor
yeah
i think yeah that is something conscious
and kind of cynical that he's doing
where he's deliberately sort of
exploiting that division even in
sort of the left-wing spectrum of
american politics yeah
yeah and he's not subtle about it i mean
he basically says
like they're going to erode democracy
and destroy it at the end right
and as i understand it they uh came out
or he came on a podcast
to explain this i didn't listen to this
but eric uh you listened to
the podcast so what additional insights
did you glean
from uh listening to that
yeah i mean the way he actually kind of
started
the podcast like backwards like he
almost started it like the end of his
essay
and then kind of went backwards and he
was like the whole point of me
like writing that piece was to give
people like a framework for
understanding the events of summer 2020
and i i thought that that was just that
that just revealed the whole game right
there because like let's explain what's
going on
in 2020 without a single reference to
kovid
without a single reference to police
brutality
or police murdering black folks let's
explain 2020
as an eruption of crypto marxism in the
leftist parties
and that that to me was just one of the
most disgusting parts about this piece
like this guy's a [ __ ] douchebag
he he's trying to teach us about why
everything's so [ __ ] up right now but
it's not because of
of a pandemic it's not because of the
history of slavery and prejudice
economic inequality in the united states
it's not because of american imperialism
and the mcdonaldization of the [ __ ]
world
is because of this crypto marxism that's
resurging
after it fell in 1989 and now it's
coming back
and he tells this ridiculous [ __ ]
story about how the liberals in the 60s
were doing good stuff but it wasn't the
student liberals it was their parents
they were passing the civil rights laws
like that was a big victory
like let's just forget that the civil
rights movement was going on for decades
and decades and was frustrated in many
of its aims and was much more radical
than any of us
understand today let's forget all that
and say that was a liberal victory
and then we skip to 1989 that's point
number two and then we skip to today
and that's his that's his [ __ ] story
that's just that's just like reverse
hagiography of marxism oh man eric is
not happy
the listeners cannot see him but eric is
leaning back
running his hands through his hair
frustratedly with pure exasperation
i don't even know what to do about this
like i'm not a political theorist or
anything but like even
like look at the near the end of his
article he writes about legitimacy
i mean by legitimacy when one party
recognizes its rivals as having a right
to rule if it wins an
election isn't legitimacy in a democracy
come from the people who elect the
[ __ ] party and not from
one party saying you're cool i hate you
but you can rule
if i lose yes like that's not legitimacy
whether what [ __ ] class at yale was
he taking
or where the [ __ ] he went to school i
think it's quite telling though that
when he talks about political legitimacy
uh the only two groups he mentions are
liberals and conservatives
who are apparently the only people who
respect democracy in this world uh
despite the victor orbans vladimir
putin's or
trump saying that he's going to cancel
or pause the election right
um he never acknowledges that the left
can in any way be respective of
democracy
and yeah and this is again what he i
mean he also commits the classic
ridiculous meme that conservatives have
you know where they bring up stalinism
as like some argument to show like how
much it failed right like this is always
the classic
kind of move that uh can the meme
conservatives like to
like to latch on to and like i think
what's what's forgotten
in in on marxism because of like the
experience with stalinism
is that like you know marx uh and like
socialism is
actually quite concerned with democracy
right like this is i mean of course a
failure of stalinism was
not enough democracy but i think like
you know
actual actual marxism or like or actual
socialism would be deeply democratic but
his claim at the end of the article
right is that
the marxist endgame is an end to
democracy or something like that which
is totally
you know the opposite point of of what
the the main concern of marxism which as
eric was saying right like
legitimacy comes from the people right
like the whole point of i think like
like a marxist analysis is to in some
ways like
re-legitimize like the the the the
sources of authority over
how we build our life together as people
as citizens
although to be fair you do have to get
rid of the bourgeoisie first
but the whole yeah i mean the whole
point of the annihilation of the
bourgeoisie
is that there's no classes anymore
because there's only two classes and
they're getting
their identity from from each other so
if you eliminate one the other's gone
except that there's more proletarians
than there are
bourgeoisies so it should be just a
numbers game who wins there
but anyway sure that's kind of where i
maybe stop being a bit of a marxist
myself but yeah that's beside the point
yeah i know i don't think any of us are
orthodox marxist here
uh i don't know victor have you
had any last-minute conversions uh since
i spoke to you last couple of a few
weeks ago
well sound off no most certainly not
being a child of
eastern europe and all that no but
what's interesting too is kind of like
how the sad thing the cynical thing in
this article really is to kind of align
the protest movements from summer 2020
like to your point eric
with marxism and to kind of like do this
thing that was done even in like
latin american countries as well when
you had like a lot of liberation
movements which were loosely affiliated
with marxism or like the catholic church
in that sense
and they were all kind of like demonized
by right-wing governments there is like
being communists kind of like being
third column
movements so there is this sort of
cynical move there where he's sort of
sidestepping the real issues of like
racial and inequality and all these
things and kind of just promoting this
conspiratorial view of like you know the
creeping influence of marxism and things
like that which
i don't know like how much of a true
believer he is but like
this is like an old kind of like
rhetorical move where any kind of like
demands for social justice are sort of
like
lumped in with stalinism and things like
that so well it's i mean it's a it's a
very comforting fantasy for the
conservative mind
exactly it is yeah it's striking also
because if you look at a lot of the
black life matters protesters and
advocates
uh take the most intellectually
sophisticated one cornell west who i
think is a great uh academic right
uh i've never once seen him appeal to
karl marx as a justification for the
protest against
uh the george floyd murder right uh he's
talked a lot about mlk
right he talked a lot about ironically
not considering uh hazoni's own
religious affiliation
uh you know our duties as good
christians and the fact that we're
trying to realize you know
the basic foundational values of our
society uh but there's really not a lot
of marks to be found about this and it's
quite telling like victor was saying
that
they're trying to really lump uh what
really is a movement against centuries
of racial oppression
uh into this old-fashioned paradigm of
usa versus marxism or the west versus
marxism
uh in order to just try to dismiss it
when they're raising very legitimate
concerns
that are certainly tied to the critique
of political economy
but aren't reducible to the critique of
political economy and what's what's
funny too is that like even like a lot
of blm activists wouldn't necessarily
identify as being marxist
like their focus is on is on
specifically the race sort of framework
not the economic framework so much
but he completely sort of like overlooks
that yeah
yeah and it's really frustrating right
and like a lot of people have said i
find it really distasteful that he
doesn't acknowledge the fact that
these people have legitimate reasons to
be protesting on these issues
and some of them very well might not be
marxist but nonetheless
um they have legitimate grievances
against the status quo
that should be acknowledged particularly
a long history of racial injustice
uh and all that's kind of sidestep by
this reductionism
matt i have like a quick question for
you because you've talked a lot more to
kind of like authors like this
and people who sort of uh promote this
sort of world view do you think
ultimately
they are just trying to kind of like um
advance a certain kind of industry
and have like a sort of a nine to five
job about this stuff or
are they really true believers in the
sense of like the threat of marxism
and these kinds of issues i was going to
ask a similar
question like this just feels like a
ploy for relevance
and it may be my the ineptitude of my
imagination but i cannot fit
this world picture into my head
no this is a [ __ ] game it's a
opportunistic takedown piece with no
substance
no but i think it does have some
substance actually to a lot of people to
read it right uh and this is part of the
problem right of
treating it in terms of the intrinsic
value of this piece as an intellectual
artifact right
and an answer to your question victor
right
i think that a lot of these authors on
the one hand definitely do believe that
what they're saying has a certain amount
of truth
but at the same time they're not really
concerned about whether or not it's a
literal truth right it's more of a
visceral or gut feeling
about what's going on and this is
something that's really important when
it comes to
progressives trying to understand how it
is that conservatives apprehend the
world
russell kirk the author of the
conservative mind put it really well
where he said
conservatism isn't so much a set of
principles as it's an outlook or an
attitude
that you take toward things right it's a
very visceral reaction
towards the world and conservatives tend
to apprehend things
through the lens of affect uh more than
their rationalist counterparts do
uh amongst liberal political theory uh
and marxist political theory or leftist
political theory more broadly
which is which is so ironic by the way
because like i feel like
like all the conservative memes these
days online it's like about like logic
and reason like all the all the
commentators right but like so many of
their arguments are based on like some
feeling they have about like society
falling apart based on like very slim
evidence
or selective evidence anyway sorry to
cut you off no no but you're absolutely
right uh but the thing is what
conservatives are doing uh in those kind
of cases are what they've always been
doing uh going back to the 18th century
uh which is recognizing that the
parlance of liberalism uh
and of scientific rationality is
extremely powerful
in the 21st century so there's no way of
jettising it and just appealing directly
to affect you have to kind of
appeal to affect through the lens of
scientific rationalism
right which is you know a different kind
of subject matter that we can talk about
uh elsewhere right you know but when it
comes to this article right i think that
a lot of people are going to sit there
and just treat this
uh as intellectually substanceless and
therefore not worthy of engagement but
it is worthy of engagement because what
this really does quite effectively
is it ties together a lot of things that
conservatives have believed for a very
long time
gives them a kind of systematic loss uh
and
presents them with an authority
uh and intellectual backing uh that a
lot of people have wanted for quite some
time
uh and through vindicating this sense of
the world coming apart because cultural
marxists um are
attacking it i'm not surprised it's
gotten the kind of rapturous response
that it has
right because it really essentially
vindicates what a lot of people have
felt viscerally for a long time on the
political right
um to try to move this forward i would
like to
ask you guys what you want to do with
this because it would be absolutely
pointless
to break this article down line by line
and show how it's not marxism
because i think anyone who's even read
communist manifesto one time
can look through this and show that it's
completely erroneous
like for example he he says races are
the new classes or something like that
marxist pit blacks against whites as the
new class warfare
so anyway like just leaving all that
aside
there's two ways forward i think we
could talk about we could talk about
actual antagonisms between
liberalism and marxism to actually
educate
our viewer our listeners on what that
actually is
or we could talk about the general
psychological impulse
that requires this person to create such
a
uh an entity
a lovecraftian entity that all of his
like followers and retweeters have to
have to rally behind so which of those
two are either of those two avenues
interesting to you or do you want to
keep railing on this article i think
both of them are kind of interesting and
actually i'd like to talk about the love
crafty and stuff
uh because just for interested listeners
one of the themes that we were thinking
of exploring
uh before this article came out was
political enemies
right uh why it is that people set up x
y or z
group as their antagonist and what the
ideological and effective appeal of that
is
and i think if we were to address things
um from this lovecraftian
tentacle um perspective that would be
kind of interesting but
i'm open to because whatever plugging
our patreon once again
that's what we were talking about last
week is how
the what what dialectics means is that
you create
your enemy just by means of you know
moving through the world and absorbing
objects this is this is a specter yeah i
think we've already kind of touched on
that too like by mentioning for example
like those old commercials from like the
80s where like
reagan's re-election campaign was just
like an image of a bear lurking in the
woods
and everybody knew what the bear
represented but it didn't have to be
like beyond the level of affect
basically it was this clear sense of
like
the enemy or the scapegoat in that sense
yeah and
that's the sort of comforting narrative
that like the author is clearly trying
to kind of like go back to in this sense
yeah
yeah and just in response to like
victor's uh kind of comment
uh i think that that kind of imagery
wouldn't necessarily be effective
uh in today's 21st planetary climate
where people tend to be a lot more
cynical and a lot more reticent
uh to overt the pro propagandistic
efforts right uh which is why you see a
lot of these
authors appeal to reason and logic and
you know facts don't care about your
feelings
uh because that kind of gestures to the
authority of
scientific rationalism and kind of
liberal open-mindedness
uh even if the figures who actually tend
to invoke this most
uh frequently don't actually embody
those norms in their
approach uh particularly to doctrines
that they don't particularly like
yeah and what's fascinating too though
like even in the sense of sort of
solidifying the in group against the out
group in that sense
is that the out group is portraying as
not having logic right so it still is
sort of like
this binary opposition but it is much
more sort of like looking to this
question of logic yeah
as sort of being on our side versus
their side
whereas like the simplest part of the
marxist logic
like to me i'm not a marxist right but
it's so simple it's
where is the surplus of your wages going
who's benefiting from it
and then how many of you are how many
are you versus how many are they
like this is just the simplest most
logical empirical open your eyes and
count
sort of logic and then you know the
marxists are paint as the hysterical
ones
when the other ones the conservatives
are worried about cthulhu
but pills yeah that's the thing like you
can't really divorce that from the sort
of like the 50 year old
cold war history here that yeah yeah we
wish we could kind of just look at it
theoretically but there is that
historical baggage which for a lot of
people
is how they primarily sort of understand
the marxist brand yeah
so eric suggested that in the podcast he
sort of gave the way
gave the game away a little bit so to
those of you who listened to the podcast
did you get any indication from his
affection
that this was a rhetorical strategy or
is this like
sincere died in the wool belief ideology
well it's kind of i mean one thing i
noticed when i listened to it which was
kind of
funny to me was like i i mean he
basically does this in the article i
guess but
it was kind of like there was a moment
where he literally said something very
close to like verbatim of
uh you know uh wokeness or like you know
critical race theory or what i'm
deciding to call marxism
like like like he literally just says
like i'm conflating these things like
that's what i'm doing here
um and he and the other thing that i
thought was kind of funny is like
he talked about the reaction to the
article as being overwhelmingly positive
uh he's like it's only been two days but
like i'm getting nothing but really
positive feedback from people people are
telling me that you know
this is like a good synthesis of what
they've what they've been thinking for a
long
time um so you got good feels
he got good feels from it he got good
feels but i mean i didn't exactly get
anything i mean he to me he's it sounds
like he
he kind of believes this and he you know
i think he does have there's underlying
it a very deep concern with
uh like being a conservative and and
holding on to traditional values like
like to some extent i i felt like the
article was
sort of gesturing you know i know he he
says he's okay with liberalism
because liberalism at least uh affirms
legitimacy of conservatism as being a a
point of view that you can vote for
but still like i kind of think his whole
critique is built to be like look like
liberalism leads to marxism
so you should be a conservative you
should be introdu believe in traditional
values well he did write a book with
nationalism in the title
defending it right am i wrong which i
should say
there are some elements to that book
that actually are surprisingly
insightful uh and this is the one thing
that i want to actually say i'm tired of
matt's charitable readings
i don't know can you just get on with
the dunk please
no no that this is what i'm getting it's
a real diamond in the [ __ ] rough
isn't it
i'm kidding man i'm kidding we all
appreciate your charitable readings
but no this is the thing though uh if
you actually read the central section of
the essay
he gives marxism a lot of credit but in
a strange way
because hezoni tends to approach the
world in terms of political antagonisms
right where he says the real world
there's oppressor and oppressed groups
he really seems to believe this
right uh and there'll always be a
dominant group and always be a
subordinate group
and liberals have not recognized that
but marxists have
and so he takes this almost a mainstream
perspective of acknowledging
the realism of his real political
opponents which is the political left
relative to
liberals uh saying they understand that
this is a war and only one side is going
to win
and we need to do everything that we
possibly can to be the victorious side
right um and
this is kind of a weird attitude that
some conservative authors sometimes take
when they're dealing with the political
app like
joseph de adopted the same perspective
when it came to jean-jacques rousseau
right that
jean-jacques rousseau was an evil man he
was destroying civilization but he was
also far smarter than most of the
liberal centrist commentators who
thought that you could
take the kind of revolutionary ideas
that he was developing
and moderate them uh because life is
ultimately an existential struggle for
power
uh and the leftists understand that the
liberals don't
uh and we on the political right also
need to understand that yeah you get
this in people like uh roy cohen
and uh roger stone i think that's their
names right like trump's lawyer
and roger like they're saying this is a
zero sum
game and everything's a game this is
just game theory we have to turn
the rubes against our political
opponents
yeah and that's the way he treats
liberals right it's like we need to turn
the liberals against the left
get them to align with conservatism uh
even though
we conservatives don't really want to be
liberals and ultimately liberalism is
also gonna have to go
in the long run but it's worked it's
shifted the entire country to the right
over the course of 30 years
but that's the strange thing about what
what he wants out of this
is that well marxism is
delegitimizing its opposition but like
and he says liberalism is a gateway to
marxism but what does he want then he
wants conservatism to win
and have a kind of neutered liberal
opposition
that can just be like the legitimizer of
their rule
but in the end the conservative
traditionalism is going to be the
position that wins out
and he he's just turning it around he's
not shy about this actually in another
article
he over overt the calls for an end to
what he calls a liberal democracy
and the advent of what he calls
conservative democracy right
that ultimately there should be a highly
traditionalist uh state
that embeds a certain ethno-religious uh
standpoint
in its laws and in his uh foundations
uh but liberals be allowed basically
some room to try to agitate and reform
so basically too much but
the modern state of israel it sounds
like he's describing
well yeah careful careful careful
which is where he's from which is what
i'm saying that's clearly how he's
approaching the world yeah i don't by
the way i don't think that there's
anything wrong with with and i think
michael brooks the lame michael brooks
was smart in saying that like you know
there's nothing wrong with criticizing
israel as as
a nation state by the way that is not
intrinsically anticipated whether or not
it's legitimate we do not need the adl
to become fans of the pill pod
no that's the thing you can't say
anything about israel because it's
anti-semitism but
he he does he does he is a nationalist
he is a religious conservative and he
does have a thing
for political strong men like orban and
like russia and like putin you know he
has a thing for them
and he's really angry that the
international community
imposes laws and universal rights and
all these things on israel and
criticizes their relationship with
palestine so he writes a book
to express how angry he is and how
liberalism
is all marxist and [ __ ] up
eric have you seen putin without his
shirt i mean he's pretty [ __ ] sexy
okay
like i don't think you acknowledge the
sex of a strong man
with a [ __ ] six-pack conservatives
love
love strong men like that exactly
they're just too sexy for
uh for the feels the conservatives sexy
for sure
effect exactly the affect but no like
this is exactly
what eric is saying i mean i think is is
exactly right that there's there's a
kind of um
that's kind of the point i was trying to
make before like that there's this weird
move to delegitimize
liberalism also because for him like
part of the key to the argument as i see
it in this article is
he's like liberalism is dangerous in a
way because it it always opens the door
to marxism right because as soon as you
affirm equal rights you're you're
opening the door to like this dangerous
path and of course there's nothing
dangerous about traditional values and
conservatism
apparently well i just want to say that
it's almost like a danielle
is listening or their algorithms are
crawling are sound bites
the opinions of our contributors do not
represent the opinions
of the people
i didn't even say anything i didn't my
own i didn't even say anything
disparaging i literally just said that
it should be okay
yeah it's enough yeah
you know in uh in the middle east they
don't even refer to it as israel they
just call it disneyland just to avoid
these kinds of
delicate issues so did you hear the news
out of disneyland last week
oh yeah i know it looks bad in there
well see ya
we should just adopt that strategy to uh
not anger your sponsors pills
yeah yeah i've been trying to
deliberately avoid that given that the
last time i got into a debate about
israel
the thread was two years ago and it's
still going on it resurrects itself oh i
think i know that thread yeah
is the pill pod is the pillpot gonna
become the only anti-disneyland podcast
on on the internet oh we've been
actually disneyland since day
two when we talked about books
so we are opposed to disneyland the
disneylandification
right right the world disneyland
yeah oh [ __ ] i'm getting into black
books territory i should shut up yeah
yeah careful
hey this is a real quote from
baudrillard i am quoting
simulation and simulacra yeah now
well i think the one thing that i wanted
to uh
iterate and this is one of the things
that i bring up in my article and it
actually
i guess relates back to the argument
that we had last week about hegel
is oddly enough i think hizoni is
actually right about the connection
between
liberalism and marxism even though he
doesn't necessarily
want to be overt about it because that
might alienate liberals and get them to
realize that they have more in common
with the political left than they do
with the political right
because i think that both liberalism and
marxism are distinctively modernist
doctrines
that are committed to the idea that
every person is a moral equal
and that they're all entitled to freedom
and really the only substantive
normative difference between liberalism
and marxism their huge
descriptive and historical differences
uh is that
marxists believe that the liberal state
is insufficient for actually
recognizing the moral equality of all
individuals and ensuring that everyone
is free
uh whereas most liberals believe that
the state as we have it right now
is sufficient uh with even even if it
needs a few cosmetic reforms here or
there
right uh whereas conservatives i
disagree with that
well why do you say i mean if we're
talking about an actual marxist
state which is only temporary by the way
but no the difference between marxism
and
liberalism perhaps the difference is
property
property rights and the right to own
property and that the state can use
violence to protect that right
okay so no no i think that's right but i
think again he gets it from rousseau of
course
but but if you and belief in the free
market too that's another big one right
the 1970s 80s neoliberal revolution
right where hayek and friedman's ideas
became the backbone of
thatcherism and reaganism right and it's
all about the free
market the government the market is so
complex
that it's useless for the government to
try to regulate it so rather we should
just have
faith that it's going to work and that
it's going to distribute
rewards and punishments where they're
liberalism like old liberalism like
rousseau comes in and says
there is no reason for you to buy into
liberalism because you're going to be
exploited no matter what and he said
this before marx mark's obviously picked
up on it
but it's saying if you don't have
property there's no
incentive for you to buy into the
liberal system because the only purpose
of it
underneath everything underneath all the
language of you know voting rights
speech rights um is just protecting
the ownership of property by one class
that exploits another
to you know work their land and work
their factories for them so that's the
difference to me
isn't that the subtext here isn't that
the subtext here
like social liberals are a bunch of
ballless freaks
and you should either just go into the
marxist side
or you should join the neoliberal free
market side
like he's he's not he doesn't want you
to be able to be like i'm a social
liberal
i believe in like certain aspects of the
free market and trade and globalization
but i also believe that the government
should step in and regulate things every
once in a while like the subtext here is
almost like
that's a position for [ __ ] so either
just
man up and become a traditionalist
conservative and believe in the
completely [ __ ] free market or go out
and join the protesters and burn down
some buildings and go to prison
like isn't that the subject here what
this guy wants to say
yeah i think that is actually in some
sense what he's trying to say right but
i think the association between
liberalism and
let's just call it marxism or the left
is more complicated than that right
because essentially what you have in
some circumstances are
uh liberals who ultimately don't believe
that
human beings are moral equals uh and you
see this expressed in people like arn
rand
sometimes fa hayek and so on and so
forth where they say uh people are
dis are unequal in their abilities and
this is reflected in the capitalist
system
and when push comes to serve uh they're
more willing to side with the political
right because ultimately they don't hold
on to the fundamental liberal principle
uh that people are more equals they just
kind of adopt liberal rhetoric about
capitalism and freedom and property
rights
because it's expedient in the given
moment right but what i think a sincere
liberalism recognizes
is basically the canteen doctrine which
is that everyone is entitled to
an equal amount of dignity uh and a
certain level of freedom
and if you genuinely believe that i
think that hazoni ironically is actually
right
that people are always going to be
attracted to marxism because what
marxism says is that
if you really believe that people are
equal and deserve freedom we don't live
in a society where people are treated
equally
or have equal freedom which means you
need to reform it
very substantially right and he talks
about this article where he says
uh you know there's this dance between
liberalism and marxism
that goes on and i think the reason that
this dance has gone on for such a long
time
is precisely because a lot of liberals
recognize that our society is highly
deficient
and they're tempted by the kind of
radical forms offered by people like
bernie sanders or offered like by people
like aoc
uh and it's the job of people like
cazone and other right-wing pundits
convince them that
they shouldn't buy into that wait sorry
are you accepting the premise
that i mean he's calling liberals
[ __ ] because they cave to the
communists
all the time but there are no [ __ ]
communists
yeah the reason yeah the reason that
they're [ __ ]
like democrat whatever like right
right lib they're fine with all these
protests is because it doesn't
touch any economic conditions they're
they're exactly they're [ __ ]
they're chilling they're sipping
champagne over occupy
wall street while people are protesting
about rights issues
and how there's not enough like
representation in hollywood or whatever
so
yeah corporation sure you should protest
that should be something that changes
for sure i think that's as economic
changes accompanies that
and that's the position of every like
even moderate leftist
and corporate america corporate they've
fully fully like integrated these like
you know
social justice ideas into their products
like nike right
now you're getting trained on how to be
like more sensitive
yeah no i i think that's definitely true
of certain kinds of world capitalism
right uh which is where the marxist
critique becomes really relevant
uh what i'm just saying is that if you
are a person who's genuinely who
genuinely adopts a liberal outlook
on things there's always going to be
this innovation to either move to the
political right and say that people are
not
equal and people do not deserve freedom
because
all their views are not equally valid or
you have to move towards the political
left by saying
yes people are equal and if they are
equal then the kind of unequal society
that we live in because of
the critique of political economy that
we can raise um
that's a serious problem and we need to
reform it right and i think what hosoni
is trying to do is
make sure that people who operate in the
political center gravitate towards a
political right
rather than the political left because
he's smart enough to recognize
that there are premises in liberalism
that can tempt many liberals to move
towards sanders and aoc and all that
particularly millennials
uh when that's not what he wants to
happen okay and i should just shout out
to our listeners if you are looking for
a position on the political spectrum
matt is a radical leftist lib
liberal socialist you can be
professional you can be proud of being a
lib and you can be on the left
but he's still a liberal cuck according
to marx's right yeah that's true
but i have long since accepted that i
just like call it period
i'm not a marxist i'm a youtuber hey man
i have the same i'm pretty
i'm very close to matt matt and i have
like very close political
positions yeah i also think that marx
was aware of this right i mean one of
the things that he says with ingles and
the communist manifesto is that
with the advent of capitalism for the
first time human beings are forced to
confront the real relations
uh that have existed since time
immemorial but have always been occluded
by
ideology and traditionalism right uh and
throughout his writings he often talks
about how it is that
liberal society in someone's senses is
quite an accomplishment because
it does at least formally treat people
as free and equal
under the law the problem is that they
aren't actually equal
in any real material sense which is why
the next stage in human history is going
to be the advent of a common society
where you finally realize true freedom
of self-determination in this
galleon sense through the advent of a
class of society
right but this isn't a break from
liberalism in the sense that liberalism
was bad and needs to be rejected
so much as it's the next stage uh
in historical process of which
liberalism was the highest form
to exist thus far you know what i mean
and
this is why i think people like azonia
really react badly to this because they
recognize that
under the right conditions a lot of
liberals can sit there and say things
like
hey yes if we do believe that people are
free and equal maybe we shouldn't
discriminate against people on the basis
that race maybe we should allow people
to practice their religion as they see
fit maybe we should sit there and try to
create something like universal
healthcare systems and so on and so
forth
yeah i i do think it is interesting that
he
argues against like he lumps
enlightenment liberalism into his
critique
and i i find that pretty interesting and
he he's kind of against this
individualism like he almost accepts
the idea of group identity but it should
be defined by
traditional values rather than by
reason and abstract principles like i
i actually like that aspect of what he's
doing because individual is a crock of
[ __ ]
and and i think i think it's it's
ridiculous that people like peterson can
still stand up there and say we're
individuals first and group
second it's like no the only reason
you're an individual is because we are
fundamentally social beings goes back to
aristotle we're political animals the
marxist
aristotle we all know but i i think
that's a step
in the right direction as to get away
from this sort of
atomism that liberalism wants is forced
on us
and we're all just individual rational
actors in a marketplace
but then he sort of goes in the wrong
direction
with the the religious nationalism and
i'm like okay no
let's take away individualism but we
don't need to put
religious nationalism and traditionalism
in there
we can put something else in there and i
guess i don't have it ready
or what that could be and that's the
critique of marxism too once this is all
gone what is marx's solution what does
the communist society actually look like
which is which is i guess that's a
legitimate critique of marxism although
like
i don't think i don't know how much marx
actually predicts that i've often
wondered this eric like
if you were to create a philosophical
system that gains enough traction
would you want to call it like tatism or
like
what would your own politicians call
because tatism is just like a weird term
like ericism is also difficult mcmanic
mcmanus welcome mcmahon uzi is in amazon
yeah i don't think that works either but
this is the problem like
because you just become a philosopher
which is
which is not as which is not as arrogant
as declaring yourself a philosopher
so step down i have a very boring
english name
that i wouldn't care to name a theory
after itation
haitian works there's a lot of words
that have my
name in it i can play with that all
right but i think we're about
but it's too british this is a it's
coming to a natural close but i just
want to shout out to our guest
uh victor litvik
ussr baby to give us the final thoughts
here
i think we we went through a very
cathartic um
like bell curve up in here i feel it was
necessary yeah
we got our rage out and now i just feel
like you guys should come down here
we'll have some
martinis yeah that'd be nice
the romanian poet such and such said no
no it's just against our clothes
i take comfort in the fact that this is
clearly kind of like
one of those reactionary sort of like
cries out
against the movement of history
basically like it just seems like back
in the 60s if somebody had been writing
about like martin luther king and trying
to like associate him with the red scare
or something it's so clearly gonna like
date itself within just a few years that
if this is how he's criticizing like
summer 2020 and blm and everything
through like sloppy connections with
marxism like
these guys have already basically lost
like if this is the best that they can
do basically yeah
that's a good point that's a good point
can i also close i was just looking
reading in the comments section
in the article and i think this is uh
this is a
a good one neil bowling says wow
simply the most amazing article i've
read anywhere in years
i'm forwarding this to everyone i know
liberal or conservative
there is so much here to digest thank
god for quillette
at one time this is the sort of high
caliber writing what could one could
find in the atlantic or the new yorker
but of course god those days are long
gone dude you you know
this is awesome there's no possible way
but by the way i have my own
i have a quick farm from the same
article a remarkable piece
with so much to consider it really
frames and explains what we've seen
happening over the past 50 years with
the weakening and destruction of our
institutional
and societal foundations most simply the
best article i've ever
had destroy that's a favorite word
anyways
okay it would be it would be um
improper to not leave the last word with
eric who's going to remind us why all of
this doesn't matter
yeah oh my god
you want me to you want me to see us off
go off
if you want to you know you know what
listeners you know
if you're if you're on our side
and you probably are if you're listening
to this unless you're
curious conservative then [ __ ] you but
and if you're 20.
if you're on our side when you're 20
then yeah
yeah just kidding by the way but if you
do encounter this kind of viewpoint
you know think of an analogy like if you
meet a creationist
you don't feel like you have to become
an expert in biology
in evolutionary biology and the history
of life
in order to argue against them just go
with your gut you're right
what he's talking about is not marxism
it's not
quote marxists know very well that their
aim is to destroy
the intellectual and cultural traditions
that are holding liberalism in place
don't let this [ __ ] quack from israel
tell you what
marxism is he doesn't he doesn't [ __ ]
know he doesn't know
disneyland anyway goofy from disneyland
we love goofy don't we folks we love
this apologies to mickey mouse and all
of his subsidiary don't listen to what
this [ __ ] guy has to say
about marxism that's all and you know
what in
200 years we're all going to be
underwater anyway yeah we're all going
to be
jingoists nationalists nationalists for
atlantis
what what's the future like pl they're
going to be planetariums in the future
when we're all inhabiting different
worlds and i'm like my world is better
than your [ __ ] world man i'm a
planetarium
you're optimistic if you think we're
going to get that far yeah it's true i
don't think we're going to have that
yeah we got to get off this rock from
the members of the pill pod
thanks so much for coming and uh yeah
if you guys want to we're just going to
keep talking after we finish recording
but you can
cancel your recordings now after you say
goodbye
okay bye-bye yeah man bye
peace it's been i don't know i don't
want to say it's been a pleasure but
it's been something
[Music]
you